for only two months away from the new  year and I want you to end the year with  a bang so I've put together an  eight-week meal prep just for you will  be cooking lots of simple delicious and  nutritious recipes let's commit and  start together on Monday - an 8th of  October  up until Sunday the 22nd of December if  you haven't yet subscribed to my  training app called Phil then do check  it out there will be exclusive monthly  worker programs by our certified  trainers healthy recipes and useful  fitness tips to get you keep me updated  with your progress daily and share your  post-workout selfie or a meal you have  prepped tagged me at Joanna so official  and hash tag a twig new me let's not  wait no more start now so click on the  links below download the meal prep  subscribe to fuel and let's end this  year strong